we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P Troy York
called in with two different characters
overnight let's listen to Troy York's
first character he called in with small
from newer Singh Park your program about
GMOs and your continual defense of it
on last week's show and previous is that
you're taking orders from somebody to
tell you to defend GMOs genetically
modified food is not healthy and you
just mentioned scientists who are paying
for by the big industry of the GMO
industrial complex in the massive amount
of propaganda and lies that they will
say to genetically modify people's food
and make them on LT and you know it and
I think the only reason oh you were
defending GMO is because most of the
owners of global business of GMO food
are of Jewish descent there's a small
community park and I just call it to
make mention of the attachment is a hack
for the GMO industry right so that's
actually Troy York that's his Jamal from
University Park character he's trying to
I guess sound stereotypically black and
it doesn't work particularly well but
his argument there is that I defend GMOs
because I'm Jewish so then he calls back
immediately and this time it's a
different character I think this is his
Italian character this is all the same
guy by the way David Pakman heard your
show this is Jacobi's and Jenna BC
thirty shows on robots and what you
didn't mention was how these companies
just produce these overpriced items to
get massive investor funding and moving
the money
alright Jacoby Genovese see that's it's
the same guy this is Troy organ
these are his various characters and
good for him he's an extremely talented
voice actor as you can tell great bonus
show today I'll tell you what happened
with my jury duty I was scheduled to
have jury duty today but I am here doing
the show I'll tell you about that and
much more on the bonus show